[Music]
just because they look similar it
doesn't mean they are the same here in
this video we will discuss and showcase
the differences between the two merse
super species the mantle color and The
Rock Critter one which was seen in
Godzilla versus Kong and the other will
be seen in Monarch the legacy of
monsters and has been showcased in an
opening sequence that was released
through the channel called IGN so let's
take a look at both of them in detail
their size body design armor habitat and
all that jazz let's get to it let's
start with their body design and Anatomy
The Rock Critters which were seen in GVK
had the appearance of a crab-like
creature with a hard carpus that was
Rocky like in substance and had small
spikes at the top they have six legs and
two arms that were formed to look like
pincers with fingers it is said that
they also had an endoskeleton along with
a h exoskeleton the mantle claw also had
the appearance of a crap likee creature
but there are stock differences which we
shall discuss in detail in a while they
also are stated to be vertebrates
meaning that even though they look like
crabs they have a skeleton underneath
along with a spinal column So based on
looks to a lay man they are more or less
the same creature but wait for the
differences and that we will showcase
and then decide okay firstly let's take
a look at their height and weight The
Rock Critter were stated in a pamphlet
to be around 15.8 M tall which then
converts to 52 ft in height and their
weight is between 7,000 and 11,000 tons
which makes them really big bigger than
the hand of an adult Kong with a mantle
Claw on the other hand as was seen in
the opening sequence released publicly
through IGM appears to be the same size
as a mother long legs so around 6 to 7 M
or 20 to 23 ft in height they do look
shorter at first due to their Crouch
stands but they can extend their body
upwards to be at the same height so the
mantle claw here is less than half the
height of a rock Critter of the hollow
Earth now let's take a look at their
facial differences The Rock Critter's
face is flat with two very visible eyes
on the top of the face separated by a
rid in the middle their face and skin is
yellowish in color contrasting with the
brownish gray of the armored car
their mouths look like beaks but with
both ends opening downwards and closing
upwards to the middle the mantle claw
has a very different phase its two eyes
are in the middle of the face covered by
an armored brow on top the coloration is
a paler Brown which Fades from the
darker brown gray of the armored hide
its mouth is made out of four pencils
which are appendages arranged two on top
and two below and besides that it also
has pip palps which are like those of a
spider that act as small arms in front
of the mouth thus this dictates that
these creatures are not the same at all
in fact very different from one another
still not convinced okay let's take a
look at their legs and claws then the
rock Critter has six legs which come out
from the back of the armored carpes they
are multi-jointed legs which gives them
a speed of 52 km/ hour which is in fact
slow for their size they also have two
large arms that end in what looks like
pincers but not quite so as the inner
half is instead composed of finger leg
appendages in fact their pincer acts
more of like a shield and they have
short muscular tails at the end of the
armor the mantle Claw on the other hand
also has six legs but they emerge from
the central part of the carpus on either
side not like the rock Critters which
come out from the back the mantle claw
also has true pincers like those of a
crab and to add to that they also have
finger like appendages which protrude
from beneath the claw the pins and also
to to add to that they also have Petty
palps which cover the face so the rock
Critter has a total of six legs two arms
and a tail while the mantle claw has six
legs with spikes on top two pencils two
hands and two Petty PS but no visible
tail now with the armor differences The
Rock Critters and the matal claws both
have similar looking exoskeleton armor
that is present on their backs which
provides them both protection as well as
camouflaging them from wbe predators
which be duck and the war bats in the
hollow Earth and many other deadly
species as of Skull Island like the
skull crawlers the killer chameleons and
even Kong but there are differences here
too The Rock crit's armor is curved and
looks rounded on top with spikes and the
rocky layer mimics the volcanic Rocky
terrain very well while the mantle
claw's armor is flatter and has sharp
edges on the sides it also has spikes on
top of that's about all the similarity
it has with the other species its arm is
also segmented as opposed to the full
piece on the other one finally let's
talk about their habit and their habitat
in the wild The Rock Critters are found
in volcanic environments it is stated
later on by Monarch after GVK that upon
the examination of the stomach contents
of a rock Critter specimen traces of
several minerals including Granite
peridotite magnesium and iron were
discovered which means that they were
not herbivores nor carnivores but
lavores LOL the mantle claw resides on a
contrasting environment while the rock
Critters were found near hot lava Fields
the mantle Claw is found near the ocean
and by the looks of its mouth it is
either a filter feeder a scavenger or
also a carnivore therefore having a
different place in the food chain Al
together but we can say that it is
territorial as well judging by the way
it fought the mother long legs that came
to its Turf near the rocky beach by the
ocean so that's all the differences
between these two super species and this
I can say say clearly they are from
different lineages and animal groups and
in no way are they closely related they
just look similar due to convergent
evolution whereby different animals
evolve similar adaptations to suit their
needs and surroundings so if you like
this video then check this other one as
well and if you're more interested in
other movie monster content then check
out our Channel as well we might just
have things that you haven't seen before
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam um